i'm like costa do you want to write a
book i'm going to write this book are
you in or are you a brother he goes i'm
in
i love it and in 45 days we got the book
out
[Music]
dr ilya grigoris thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
thank you for having me i appreciate it
it's good to be here
it's going to be so much fun i'm going
to spend the next 20 minutes learning
how to be happier and how to navigate
through crisis better because these are
the two
two books that you've that you've
written the first one a best-selling
book
the second one i'm guessing is already
on its way to becoming a best-selling
book
so it just came out so i hope so and you
actually
have it next to you so let me see the
cover let me see how it looks the new
book is seven keys to navigating a
crisis
a practical guide to mostly dealing with
pandemics and other disasters and you
know we're going through a multitude of
crisis at the same time right now so
before right yes yes okay so we're going
to get there in a second but first i
need to know to be happier
and i'm very excited for this so so you
know maybe just
give me a couple of those you know the
key earned insights
over your decades of research what what
is happiness and why do we
yearn for it so much this concept first
of all happiness is a choice
let's let's make and it takes work
however it comes easier for some other
than others
but i will tell you this i get to speak
internationally i travel around the
world speaking on happiness and wellness
in every country the first question i
ask the audience is this
if you were to ask any parent regardless
of nationality ethnicity
religious affiliation socioeconomic
status
gender whatever what would you like for
your children
the answer is always i just want them to
be and then i take the microphone and i
point to the audience
happy everybody's because that's a
universal need right
we are here on this earth to be happy so
uh the easiest way of course and is you
cannot be
grateful and be sad at the same time so
to have an attitude of gratitude
is and that's pretty well known what i
want to raise the bar a little bit
because it's easy to be grateful when
everything is going well that's the
easiest thing in the world
i say that we're all graduates from the
same university the university of
adversity
so if the older we get the more
experiences you have the higher the
degree
so by the time you get to be my age you
have gray hair you have multiple phds in
adversity in life
meaning that we're all going to lose
people we love
our grandparents first and then our
parents at some point maybe a spouse or
a or a
sibling god forbid a child we're going
to have financial
crisis we're going to have health crisis
be it cancer heart disease diabetes and
so on
we're going to have relationships
divorces things that are not going to
work out
so all of these things are part of the
human existence right
so the key of course now is can you be
grateful in the midst of
crisis can you be grateful when you're
facing adversity in life
because when things are going well like
i said it's easy to be happy that's in
to be grateful
but can we be grateful in the midst of
the darkness of life
in and i want to ask you that what do
you think is that possible even
it has to be otherwise this is going to
be a very sad conversation
so i'm going to say that it has to be it
has to be yes
and and the key of course to that is to
me nothing bad has ever happened in my
own personal life and
in the thousands of patients i used to
be a clinical psychologist my first half
of the prac
in my life before i switched over to the
corporate side
everybody faces these things some of
them multiple times
and sometimes at the same time which is
which is very difficult
but to me either you're you're learning
something
or you're winning there's no losing in
life
right if you learn the lesson so out of
the toughest the most
the darkest of times i've actually
learned more than my successes
right and then you use those to
move forward right in life so
don't don't be afraid of adversity
because at first it's coming and we're
getting it now in spades
actually in humanity as we speak right
now
and i do want to go to that you know we
got multiple crisis
we got the covet 19 we have the
financial crisis in the economic crisis
as a result of the shutdown
we have a mental health crisis just in
the united states alone
after the first two months we don't have
the statistics yet before
from the month of may yet depression
anxiety
stress related disorders up an
astonishing 700 percent
700 700 these are new people that are
not people that have pre-existing
conditions mind you these are
specifically as a result
of the pandemic and then of course you
have the
the racial strife and everything that's
happening in the streets right now as we
speak
and so to have four crisis
simultaneously is very unusual
now i'm an optimist by nature and i will
tell you this that
humanity may be done on on one knee and
maybe struggling a little bit and we're
getting a beating right now
but we will overcome this let there be
no doubt
and i also want to share with you that
there are four types for personality
types when
when dealing with crisis and there's a
there's a big differentiation between
danger and fear
if somebody comes up to you and coughs
in your face right now you're in danger
that's real
fear however is not your friend
so we don't want to make decisions
whether as individuals or as companies
in the where the corporate world are in
organization based on fear because those
are not good decisions
right so now let's talk about the four
personality types
number one is the victim
the victim is all why is this happening
to me you know this always happens to me
poor me
right poor me the second personality
type
is what we call the critic now the
critic
regardless of what the federal state or
local you know government or the health
care officials that they couldn't set
everything for example
you should wear a mask when you go
outside well that's stupid
okay okay don't wear a mask when you go
outside well that's stupid too like no
matter what comes up
it criticizes everything right no matter
it doesn't matter what it is
the third group we'd like to call the
bystander they make the most noise right
they by the way they're very loud
they're very loud but they offer no
solutions this is important
the third group we call the bystander
now the bystander is a good person
but basically the python is overwhelmed
by fear and really doesn't know what to
do
like this is a huge wave of unknown i
feel out of control my life is out of
control i don't know what to do
so they look to the left they look to
the right they look at their neighbor
but basically there they have the deer
with the headlights look and they do
nothing
and all three of these personality types
have one thing in common
they offer no solution right the victim
doesn't the critic certainly doesn't and
neither does the bystander now we get to
the fourth type and the fourth type we
like to call the navigator
and then this is the premise of this
book right that we all should become
navigators the navigator begins with a
positive attitude and says look
no matter what happens we will overcome
this practice as
self-care which is the first key to
navigating a crisis meaning they take
care of themselves
in order to be successful and then
they're flexible and adaptable
people with this new normal if you think
you can go on and do business as usual
and expect to have successful results
you're
sadly mistaken right yeah everything is
completely different right now in the
last
90 90 days to four months so
and why is flexibility important so we
like to use the example of the oak tree
in the pantry
the oak tree symbolically speaking think
about this the octa is this massive
strong tree that's been around for a
hundred years
huge strong right but if there's enough
moisture
enough rain and enough wind at the top
of the storm the hurricane guess what
happens to oak trees they come crashing
down
on cars people homes and so on the palm
tree on the other hand
is thin tall and but very flexible at
the top of the hurricane 150 miles
yes it goes it can go parallel to the
ground but when the storm passes
and think about the storm of life right
not the actual storm it raises up again
and survives
yeah up and down so we're asking people
now
to to be flexible like a palm tree don't
be a note 3 and say well that's how i've
done things for the last 30 years i'm
not changing
you're going to break if you stay like
that you need to be flexible
because you also have a lot of
experience working with corporates and
you when you transition from clinical
work to to the private sector and now
you're helping leaders and and i'm going
to take myself for example
one day i'm going to have a company of
my own and i hope to have
a thousand employees which i can lead
that ship uh wherever we go
now the question is is it really
reasonable to try and aim for
for all of the employees in the
organization to be
navigators or or do you want to have
some critics some some bystanders or do
you really want everybody to be
navigators here
this is a fantastic question and here's
why
the critic the the victim
the bison and the navigator all exist
within every human being
we all have those personalities within
us right yeah
and i'll tell you this when this first
hit i was the bystander all my speaking
engagements that i had
set up throughout the world guess what
happened cancelled yeah
i'm like holy now what do i do right and
i kind of felt like a victim a little
bit i'm like
oh no why is this happening to me and
believe me there are things that the
government has done that i criticize
very open i'm like that is stupid i mean
look i see people driving in their car
sometimes by themselves wearing a mask
hello there's nobody else in the car
but man here's the important thing i
didn't stay a victim
i didn't stay in critical mode and i
didn't stay as a bystander
i decided to do something about it and
the result of actually that of the
navigating is writing a brand new book
i had no plans in 2020 to write a book
beautiful
i had this impression that i needed to
do and i called my partner i'm like
he's greek i'll say i'm like costa do
you want to write a book i'm going to
write this book are you in or are you a
brother
he goes i'm in i love it and in 45 days
we got the book out
to put our perspective my first book
took three years to write
just so you so that's right that's what
navigation looks like so do we want all
our employees to be navigators you're
darn right we do
you know i think that's incredible
specifically because just yesterday i
spoke with
a professor dan ariely who's a good
friend and a mentor behavioral economics
a hero predictably rational and and he
said that one of the things
his advice to us was that when he has a
plane that is delayed
he sits down and uses that opportunity
to write a children's book and he
only writes the children's book when his
fight is delayed so he's turning that
situation from a victim point
why is this happening to me to oh i have
an opportunity to now and work on a
project that i never had the chance
so i i i'm seeing all these patterns
with very successful people and
i'm starting to adopt this mindset so if
we want we want everybody to be
navigators but also more importantly
because of the other book too we want to
be happy navi
navigators we don't want you to just
navigate and be what does that mean
what does that mean being a happy
navigator to me it means that you enjoy
the process
you truly enjoy the journey when we talk
in the corporate world i started talking
about happiness the corporate world
before all the studies
back that up right because they used to
think like
happy employees i pay them why do they
need to be happy for
i'll tell you why they need to be happy
because happy employees
number one they're physically healthier
that means they have less time off
because they're healthier
okay they're more collaborative they're
better team players
because they're happier there's greater
retention right
people don't you know they leave they're
loyal they love where they work
and as a result of that they're more
productive right guess what happens when
you have a productive workforce
your company is more profitable well
what's happening now in silicon valley
you know every other day we see of
another
allegation or accusation of companies
cultures they're just going down and and
it seems that company culture in 2020
is one of the most important aspect that
a founder has to work on
so where do you come into this to this
arena what's happening and
why are companies suffering from their
lack of happiness or culture
because their their focus should be
where when you treat your employees
poorly
guess how your employees treat your
customers poorly
yeah when you treat your employees well
guess how they treat your customers they
treat your customers well
there's a direct link between the way
that you treat people so
in the rush especially nowadays with the
economy being shut down for
uh 60 to 90 days hr directors right now
are having a very difficult time because
the ceo now the ramping up again economy
businesses are
coming back on again right now they're
like hey listen
our revenue we're behind schedule by 60
to 90 days
what our goals were for the for this
year we
the employees need to work two times or
three times as hard as they did before
that's where their ceo is coming from
now the employees on the other hand who
are coming back
and not all of them because some of them
are going to stay at home they're not
they're going to refuse to come to work
they've been traumatized by all this so
many things have happened out of their
control
so the seniors i call you know the
c-suite basically senior leaders
need to treat employees completely
different than before
and they need to say look i know we have
to hit that numbers by the end of this
month
but here's the why behind it like they
need to step up their own game
and communicate to the employees as to
why i'm asking you to hit those numbers
because if we don't i may have to lay
off 25
of the workforce and i don't want to do
that the enlightened leader will use
those words and say
you're part of my family i don't want to
have to let go of any one of you
i need you to work harder so we can hit
those numbers
so everybody is still employed next
month and not to do it in a fear-based
mode
where you do it or else but truly do it
in an empathetic
caring and compassionate mode to say
listen we're all in this together
we're all struggling none of us expected
to have almost zero revenue for 90 days
so we're way behind the eight ball
i do need your help i do need you to
work 14 hours but i
but i'm doing it because i also want you
to be here at the end of the year so we
can all be standing together
and united if they don't do that and
they just focus on the bottom line
these people are already scared they're
already down they're already depressed
and traumatized
you have that kind of pressure on top of
that you're not going to hit your goals
so it sounds like if i thought that that
until now
was the real test of leadership it
sounds like actually the reopening is
going to be just as great a test
on how do you now treat how do you
understand and empathize with the new
situation and your new employees
quote unquote that it's not just like
you froze for 90 days and you came back
to reality but reality continued it
diverted and now you have a new reality
to work with
and and you use two key words empathy
meaning in other words you have
senior leaders need to show increased
emotional intelligence
like a lot more than they ever have
before that's number one and then number
two
in some ways you're re on boarding all
your employees
like as if they're new employees because
this is a new truly it's a new normal
and people say i hate to use that term
but guess what the new normal will
become the new normal
because things are changing so rapidly
we really don't know even what the fall
will bring
yeah nobody can really predict will it
will be there be a second wave
how bad will it be will it happen in
september and november
when the flu season kicks in people
don't really know
so this is the reason why it's important
to have to take care of your employees
now more than ever
dr gregory's why are you so passionate
about this why
go get a phd on psychology and focus on
happiness writes two books
you you're the president of an
organization that
helps thousands of people be happier why
why
because i feel like my purpose in life
and i've known this since i was a young
man actually is to make a difference in
this world
and i feel this world right now is
really struggling i need to have my own
game
like writing this book in 45 days i had
to have my own game and my own
expectations
because normally i'm like you know i'm
kind of greek like uh whatever you know
we'll get there when we get there
no there's an urgency to do things right
and to do them now
because people are hurting and they're
struggling now not next november not in
2021 or 2025 we need to help them now
and organizations need that help now
and you know and and this comes from an
optimist by the way you know i'm not
like the sky is falling a pessimistic
guy
but i see what's out there and i feel
and i feel deeply
so for me yes happiness is the most
important thing in life
um senior leaders
need to have a different mindset going
into this it's not business as usual
your workforce is not the same that it
was 90 days ago i promise you
so many things have changed so be
sensitive to that
and the words that you also use
compassion kindness
understanding over communicate to the
point where your employer goes boss
enough that's the 10 times you told me
that you care about me i got it i got to
go to work now
like i know it's kind of silly what i'm
saying but you know what i mean though
like you have to
overdo it yes over communicate in
in and show them that that's a downfall
of a lot of leaders right that they
under communicate
and instead of over communicate in other
words we can't afford to take shortcuts
as a leadership right now not this time
not this time so uh and and i'm
i'm really excited for where you're
going with your life i tell you that i i
did my research on you
you're a wonderful young man and i see
nothing but success in front of you
thank you i i thank you i i i really
appreciate it and
you know one of the reasons why i
enjoyed this so much like we spoke
before is because i'm i get to learn of
all these different industry
and when when else would i get to speak
to a happiness
expert and you know gain in even you
know if i take three
takeaways from this on over
communication and
and having empathy for for my colleagues
and employees and employers
and being a navigator instead of a
critic or instead of a bystander i mean
just those three things are priceless
lessons that i learned and hopefully my
friends who are watching this will also
will also
enjoy doctor before we leave and i can't
believe 20 minutes are almost up it's
it's so disheartening
fast yeah it goes fast i i want to know
three words that best describe you
well happiness is number one i mean my
nickname is that you're you're the
happiness doctor basis so happiness is
one
i think there's nothing more important
to me than family and
the family you know unit the people that
i love the most and then you know my
faith
and whether your faith isn't god or your
faith isn't you know the divine or your
faith is whatever you want to describe
it that
you know we will overcome this let there
be no doubt
the vaccine will come the drugs were
getting very close to having the drugs
already
and i love the fact that humanity is
working together
you know all the scientists from all
over the world are working together we
have a common enemy
an invisible enemy and listen
human has been up against the wall
before this is not going to be the end
of us we will be
better as a result of it and even in the
corporate world i think they'll be
better the work working from home or the
or the
some of the differences that we're
seeing right now uh in new ways
there'll be more innovation that we've
seen in quite a while because that's
what
crisis brings about is the need for
innovation
so that's another plus so don't give up
keep the faith be happy i love it okay
last question just because it's really
fascinating me now
where are we headed with the research on
happiness what is left to uncover
so we know we want to be happy we have
an idea of
things that of how to deal with
adversity but but what is left to
uncover
on this big question of happiness i
think though the one thing that
although they have been said it has to
do with kindness because
yes self-care is important but it's it's
in the end
why why are we doing all this is to help
one another
i want to talk to your audience if
you're feeling sorry for yourself if you
feel like man i have a sort if things
are
really hard right now i promise you
there's somebody else out there whose
life is a lot worse than yours
100 find that person in in
an act of service it could be a text it
could be a phone call
if you get that prompting i need to call
michael i'm not going to put it off i'm
going to call michael say
how are you doing and you know in
america here the
the answer is always i'm doing fine and
i'm going to say no no no how are you
really doing
is between you and i now this is what
this is what managers need to do with
their employees
they need to ask the second question
don't not just the token
how are you doing because most people
are going to say fine i'm like no let me
close the door
i see you're counting this i see your
face i see your eyes i think you're
struggling
tell me what i can do to help you i
think this is the greek part of you
that's coming out
from the from yeah yes
it is you know because we love you know
there's a word in greek philosonia means
the love of strangers in essence so
we have to go the extra mile and help
those
around us and there's need all around
by the way when happy people are kind by
nature
on the other hand when you perform an
act of kindness that makes you happy on
the inside
so with kindness and happiness you can't
have one without the other in essence
so i maybe there need to be more study
of that connection between those two
kindness and happiness
i love it dr gregory thank you so much
for your time for the inspiration
i can't wait to order your book and read
it and navigating crisis i can't believe
you wrote it in 45 days that must be
something i had helped i had help
with all the help in the world bringing
an idea to production in 45 days it's
it's mind-blowing so so i can't wait to
read it and
thank you for taking the time to do this
thank you for having me on your program
thank you
take care